keeping on top of your pet's health is
just as important as monitoring your own
cancer is unfortunately common in dogs
and there are a number of different
types of cancer that affect them some
more serious and invasive than others
and all require veterinary attention
the earlier cancer can be detected the
better the chances of successful
treatment that's why it's so important
to bring your dog to the vet for routine
wellness exams and the first signs of
any illness dr j.b ogenstein of oasis
animal hospital in henderson says the
majority of her clients stayed up to
date with their pet exams during the
pandemic
she says it's important to know what's
normal and abnormal on your pet so she
recommends the following make sure
you're touching your pet all over you
know running you're not just petting the
top of the head and down the back but
actually literally running your hands
over the body
under the jaw down the legs into the
armpits
down the back legs into the groin and
just feeling
so you know what's normal on your pets
this should happen a minimum of once a
month but as your pet gets older more
frequently she says as some of the
aggressive tumors can grow fairly
quickly